this Ukrainian boy was trapped in rubble
from a Russian missile strike
rescued alive only to die hours later in
the southern city of mikalayev as
Ukraine endured another day of pain
what to do about Russia's War dominated
a meeting of NATO allies in Brussels
new pledges of weapons for Ukrainian
forces were made but there are also
fears Vladimir Putin could resort to a
nuclear strike the alliance is usually
very careful when talking about how it
might respond but France this week
appeared to break with that convention
the French president has said that
France would not retaliate with nuclear
weapons should Russia launch a nuclear
strike against Ukraine or in the region
would NATO consider a nuclear response
to such an attack circumstances in which
NATO might have to use nuclear weapons
are extremely remote
Russia's nuclear retric is dangerous
Reckless and they know that if they use
nuclear weapon against
Ukraine it will have severe consequences
outside is a piece of the Berlin Wall
history has taught NATO rarely to
discuss nuclear policy for fear of
escalation
but this place is a nuclear Alliance and
it conducts an annual exercise to
practice the act of dropping nuclear
bombs from the air though without using
live weapons that training is happening
next week hosted by Belgium I understand
some 14 Nations will be involved
deploying up to 60 aircraft including
fighter jets that can carry nuclear
warheads they'll operate over the North
Sea including probably into UK airspace
I asked the British defense secretary if
pushing ahead was wise given the
tensions with Moscow this is a routine
exercise and it's all about readiness
you know today you know the NATO meeting
is all about making sure we are ready
for anything
that includes
includers still meeting with President
Putin like turkey's president here on
the left
contact at a time of conflict an
unpredictable combination
Deborah Haynes Sky News Brussels